[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
well that was exciting smuggled in like
Cleopatra in the carpet yeah
sorry for the cloak-and-dagger rayel and
you must be Oedipus Roy oh I'm too late
are we this way yeah over here
sorry about the commotion outside
rheya jerel Logan Roy dad
Ranger oh it's lovely to have you these
have a seat how can I get you something
to drink just water thanks quite a few
mmm
Lady Liberty so the agenda of the
meeting is just sort of you know
check-in on how we can all better work
together to protect journalists in
hostile environments and yeah yeah thank
you for the cover story we don't need to
bother with all that we know you're
interested in an acquisition again and I
have a message yeah
the message would be on behalf of the
Pierce family and the media organization
it is privately owned for a hundred and
fifty years the message would be a
typically balanced nuanced an objective
fuck-off very nuanced and is that the
view of the whole family
they're united than that well I don't
involve myself in the palace intrigue
but overall the family knows what you're
after and they're not interested I mean
what am i after you're playing your
favorite tune again no only this time I
take it some genius bankers convinced
you that the only way to keep the
Jackals out is to leverage yourself
until you're too big to take down well I
can assure you that is not a fair
characterization of what we're doing
here look what do they want The Pierces
in general who knows so there is a price
all I can say is that at this point the
position is they're not interested in
you what do you think I think they're
amazing custodians so you don't have a
position on who your owner is because
that would presumably affect things
if you wade in I'm a chief executive I
take my orders from the board and
mere tool well huh anyway I hope this
hasn't been too disappointing it's been
fun you know I want Pierce but it only
works for me fast very fast so please
stay have lunch oh my tummy is delicate
we really only eat Pulitzer over it
Pierce you eat I'll uh stay for five and
skulk out the way I scope in
you